SEE YOU BACK HERE TOMORROW
NIGHT AT 7:00.
THAT’S OUR STORY.
TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
WE HAVE EXCLUSIVE REPORTING
ON HOW GOOGLE MAY BE
STALKING YOU, TRACKING YOUR
EVERY MOVE.
>> EVEN IF YOU THINK YOU
KNOW HOW SURVEILLANCE
CAPITALISM WORKS.
THIS WILL SHOCK YOU, IT
SHOCKED US.
WE HAVE AN INVESTIGATION
GOING UP IN A MINUTE.
WE WANT TO START WITH THE
BIGGEST NEWS DEVELOPMENT OF
THE DAY.
THERE IS STILL NO EVIDENCE
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUDED
WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
HUNDREDS OF JOURNALISTS AND
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATORS, TENS
OF MILLIONS OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS MORE THAN YEAR
RELENTLESS SEARCHING THAT
HAS BASICALLY SHUT THE
GOVERNMENT DOWN.
IN THE END, NOTHING.
BUT THAT DOESN’T MEAN WE
HAVEN’T LEARNED A GREAT DEAL
ABOUT HOW OUR GOVERNMENT
ACTUALLY WORKS.
WE HAVE.
JUST TODAY ANOTHER TROVE OF
FBI TEXT MESSAGES BECAME
PUBLIC.
LAST NIGHT THE SENATE
RELEASED A CRIMINAL REFERRAL
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AGAINST CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
HE’S THE SHADOWY AUTHOR OF
THE TRUMP DOSSIER.
SO THERE IS AN AWFUL LOT
GOING ON.
HERE’S SOME OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENTS IN
THE LAST 24 HOURS.
NOW, YOU REMEMBER IN THE
SPRING OF 2016, PRESIDENT
OBAMA WAS ASKED IF THE
PUBLIC COULD HAVE CONFIDENCE
THAT HIS ADMINISTRATION
WOULD NEVER TAMPER WITH THE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
HE RESPONDED
UNEQUIVOCALLABLY QUOTE, I
GUARANTEE THAT THERE NO
POLITICAL INFLUENCE IN ANY
INVESTIGATION CONDUCTED BY
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OR
THE FBI IN ANY CASE, FULL
STOP, PERIOD.
THAT SOUNDED DEFINITIVE.
AND, YET, NEWLY RELEASED FBI
TEXTS SUGGEST THAT MAY BE
FALSE.
JUST FIVE MONTHS AFTER OBAMA
MADE THAT CLAIM, FBI
ATTORNEY LISA PAGE TEXTED
SENIOR AGENT PETER STRZOK
WITH WHOM SHE WAS HAVING AN
AFFAIR TO SAY, THIS QUOTE:
POTUS WANTS TO KNOW
EVERYTHING WE’RE DOING.
NOW, KEEP IN MIND AT THE
TIME THAT PAGE WROTE THE
HILLARY CLINTON
INVESTIGATION HAD BEEN
CLOSED BUT THE INVESTIGATION
OF DONALD TRUMP HAD BEGUN.
THE FBI CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS
WATCHING CLOSELY.
THAT’S THE HEADLINE FROM
TODAY’S BATCH OF TEXTS.
THERE ARE MANY MORE TEXTS ON
THE WAY.
REMEMBER THOSE FIVE MONTHS
OF TEXT MESSAGES HAVE
SOMEHOW LOST THEY HAVE
SOMEHOW BEEN FOUND.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
THEM AND CONGRESS IS WAITING
TO GET THEM.
CAN YOU EXPECT MORE
REVELATIONS TO COME.
LAST NIGHT AS WE SAID THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
RELEASED A REDACTED VERSION
OF CRIMINAL REFERRAL DOSSIER
AUTHOR CHRISTOPHER STEELE A
KERRYFULLY WRITTEN DOCUMENT
AND PACKET WITH INFORMATION.
GOT FAR LESS ATTENTION THAN
THE NOW FAMOUS DEVIN NUNES
MEMO BUT MAY TELL US MUCH
MORE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE SENATE MEMO
RELEASED LAST NIGHT EXPLAINS
HOW CHRISTOPHER STEELE
DELIBERATELY MISLEAD THE FBI
ABOUT THE DOSSIER HE
ASSEMBLED.
STEELE TOLD FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS HE HAD NOT
SPOKEN TO ANY MEDIA OUTLETS
ABOUT HIS RESEARCH.
IN FACT, HE HAS SPOKEN TO
MANY OF THEM, INCLUDING THE
"NEW YORK TIMES," "THE
WASHINGTON POST," YAHOO
NEWS, THE NEW YORKER AND
CNN.
THAT’S NOT FORGETFULNESS.
IF THIS MEMO IS ACCURATE,
STEELE LIED TO THE FBI.
AND THAT’S A FEDERAL CRIME.
BUT MAYBE MORE IMPORTANT,
THANKS TO STEELE’S
DECEPTION, THE FBI RELIED ON
A YAHOO NEWS REPORT TO
VERIFY THE DOSSIER WHEN, IN
FACT, THE YAHOO STORY WAS
ITSELF SIMPLY CITING THE
DOSSIER.
CIRCULAR.
IT WOULD BE PRETTY FUNNY IF
IT WEREN’T SO INCOMPETENT.
YET, HERE IS THE STRIKING
THING.
EVEN AFTER THE FBI LEARNED
THAT STEELE WAS LYING TO
ELM.
THIS THEY CONTINUED TO USE
HIS DOSSIER TO JUSTIFY
SPYING ON CARTER PAGE.
AS THE SENATE MEMO MAKES
CLEAR, THERE ARE ONLY TWO
POSSIBLE EXPLANATIONS FOR
THIS.
EITHER THE FBI LIED TO THE
FISA COURT BY SAYING STEELE
HAD NOT SPOKEN TO
JOURNALISTS BEFORE OCTOBER
OF 2016, THAT’S ONE.
OR, TWO, STEELE LIED TO THE
FBI AND IS THEREFORE A
DISCREDITED SOURCE.
NEITHER ONE IS GOOD.
BOTH ARE BAD.
THERE IS MORE.
THE SENATE MEMO DESCRIBES
STEELE AS SLOPPY AND
RECKLESS RESEARCHER, INTENSE
PARTISAN WITH PASSIONATELY
LEFT-WING VIEWS ABOUT
AMERICAN POLITICS WHO
INCLUDED UNSOLICITED,
UNVERIFIED ALLEGATIONS IN
HIS ASETTLEMENTS YOU,
APPARENTLY SOME OF THOSE
ALLEGATIONS CAME FROM
HILLARY CLINTON’S OWN
ASSOCIATES, THAT’S THAT
SEEMS ODD SINGS THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN WAS HELPING TO PAY
FOR THE DOSSIER IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THERE YOU GO.
AS MEMO PUTS IT DRY
UNDERSTATEMENT.
ALL OF THIS QUOTE RAISES
ADDITIONAL CONCERNS ABOUT
STEELE’S CREDIBILITY.
YEAH, THAT’S FOR SURE.
IN FACT, IT’S HARD TO SEE
HOW ANY FAIR PERSON COULD
DISAGREE WITH THAT SENTENCE.
YET, SORE SOME REASON, THE
FBI SEEM TO HAVE NO CONCERNS
ABOUT STEELE’S CREDIBILITY.
HIS WORK, THE DOSSIER
APPEARS TO FORM THE BASIS OF
THIS ENTIRE INVESTIGATION.
IF THERE IS MORE EVIDENCE
OUT THERE THAT POINTS TO
COLLUSION DURING THE 2016
CAMPAIGN, WE HAVEN’T SEEN
IT.
WE HAVEN’T EVEN HEARD
WHISPERS OF IT AT A MOMENT
LIKE THIS LEAKS ARE THE
REALM.
PRIMARY WAY PEOPLE
COMMUNICATE INFORMATION,
IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE WE
HAVEN’T HEARD OF ANY OTHER
EVIDENCE.
SO MAYBE THERE ISN’T ANY.
IS THE STEELE DOSSIER THE
ENTIRE THING ALL THEY HAVE
GOT IN THE STEELE DOSSIER
SEEMS TO ME THE REASON WE
ARE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THAT DOES NOT INSPIRE
CONFIDENCE.
CONGRESSMAN MATT GETZ IS A
REPUBLICAN REPRESENTING THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> GOOD TO BE ON, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO POINT
OUT A STORY WE HAD ON LAST
NIGHT THE DAILY MAIL BROKE.
THE LEAD ON THE RUSSIA PROBE
IN THE HOUSE AMONG DEMOCRATS
WAS SUCKERED IN A PRANK
PHONE CALL INTO BELIEVING
THAT THE UKRAINIAN GROUP HAD
NAKED PICTURES PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS REPORTEDLY HAVING
AN AFFAIR WITH HE THEN
DISPATCHED RESEARCHER OR
AIDE ON THE COMMITTEE TO
CALL BACK THE NUMBER AND SET
UP A DOCUMENT DROP AT THE
UKRAINIAN EMBASSY.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A
SIGNIFICANT STORY.
IT’S NOT BEING COVERED
TODAY.
DO YOU THINK THAT’S A
MEANINGFUL THING TO KNOW?
>> ABSOLUTELY, TUCKER.
ADAM SCHIFF SHOULD STEP
ASIDE AS THE LEAD DEMOCRAT
ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE AS A CONSEQUENCE
OF THIS SCANDAL.
WHILE OUR FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT WERE SUFFERING
THROUGH AN OBAMA NATION, AN
OBAMA INFLUENCE WITH THESE
AITEMS TO INFLUENCE
INVESTIGATIONS, HAD YOU ADAM
SCHIFF OFF PLAYING FOOTIES
WITH THE UKRAINIANS TRYING
TO GET NAKED PICTURES OF
DONALD TRUMP.
ADAM SCHIFF HAS GONE WITH
SOMEONE WITH OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES TO AN
ACTUAL PRINCIPLE IN THIS
INVESTIGATION ENGAGING IN
THE UKRAINIANS AND I THINK
FOR BETTER OBJECTIVITY, HE
OUGHT TO STEP ASIDE.
>> Tucker: CORRECT ME IF I
AM WRONG, AND I’M REALLY
TRYING TO BE OPEN-MINDED
BECAUSE MAYBE TRUMP COLLUDED
WITH PUTIN.
I’M WAITING FOR THE
EVIDENCE.
BUT THE ALLEGATION APPEARS
TO BE THIS.
THAT TRUMP’S ASSOCIATES,
INCLUDING ONE OF HIS
CHILDREN SPOKE TO A RUSSIAN
LAWYER IN AN EFFORT TO GET
DAMAGING INFORMATION ON THE
OTHER CAMPAIGN, ON A
POLITICAL RIVAL, HILLARY
CLINTON.
ADAM SCHIFF IS BASICALLY
ADMITTED THAT HE SOUGHT
DAMAGING CAMPAIGN POLITICAL
RIVAL FROM A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT.
WHY IS THAT DIFFERENT?
>> WELL, EVEN MORE ANALOGOUS
WOULD BE JEFF SESSIONS.
JEFF SESSIONS WAS TALKED
INTO RECUSING HIMSELF
BECAUSE OF A HAND SHAKE IN A
GREETING LINE.
HERE YOU HAVE ADAM SCHIFF
ENGAGING WITH UKRAINIANS
TRYING TO DIG UP DIRT ON THE
PRESIDENT WITH SEEMINGLY NO
INTEREST IN WHETHER OR NOT
THE INFORMATION IS TRUE OR
FALSE OR DOCTORED.
IF YOU USE THE SAME STANDARD
APPLIED TO SCHIFF HE SHOULD
HAVE NO ROLE AS A LEAD ON
THIS ISSUE.
IF YOU LOOK AT HIS
CREDIBILITY WITH THE